[Music]
to understand a few concepts related to
atoms let's begin with two simple
elements hydrogen and helium apart from
the difference in the number of
electrons and their structure can you
tell me another difference between these
two yes
the most important difference lies in
the fact that hydrogen is capable of
reacting with several other elements
while helium never really does helium is
a quiet unreactive element that does not
participate in reactions but have you
ever wondered why what makes helium and
many other elements also like neon argon
not participate in chemical reactions
and another question we would have is
what makes other elements react
spontaneously with each other
the answer is valency yes one of the
most important factors for reaction is
the concept of valency but before that
let's have a look at an important
concept called the electronic
configuration now what could this be as
the name suggests electronic refers to
electrons and the term configuration
literally means arrangement or layout
that means the electronic configuration
of an atom is the arrangement of its
electrons in the shells as simple as
that there are two facts that we need to
recall first the innermost shell or the
first shell rather has a maximum of two
electrons that can be accommodated in it
secondly from the second shell onwards
whichever is the outermost shell it can
accommodate a maximum of eight electrons
in simpler words outermost orbital can
contain eight electrons at max this
state is called as the octet state the
term originates from the Greek word octa
which means eight the octet state is
considered to be a stable state let's
understand this in a simple way you love
chocolates now if there is a bag of
chocolates kept open before you how many
will you try to
but once needless to say you will try
and take as many chocolates as your hand
can accommodate that means the maximum
number of chocolates is what anybody
will wish for now what have chocolates
got to do with electronic configuration
and valency let's understand the
relation as a part of human tendency we
will try and grab the maximum number of
chocolates using our hands
similarly the atoms would want to have
maximum number of electrons their shells
can accommodate that means if it's just
one shell like in the case of hydrogen
or helium then the atoms would want to
have two electrons in it that will be
the outermost shell of the atom this
will help them achieve a stable State
similarly for all the other atoms having
more than one shell it's obvious that
they will wish to have eight electrons
in their outermost shell and why is this
so that's correct it's because the
outermost orbital of any atom can
accommodate a maximum of eight electrons
in it that is the reason why all the
atoms of various elements are in a
constant struggle of attaining eight
electrons in the last shell that is
achieving the octet state however it's
not possible for all to have eight
electrons in the outermost shell imagine
the case of oxygen it has a total of
eight electrons so can we just have one
orbital around the nucleus containing
all the eight electrons absolutely not
in fact according to the rule we have to
fill two electrons in the first and the
remaining six electrons in the second
shell because the capacity of the first
shell is to accommodate a maximum of two
electrons so can we say that the
electronic configuration of oxygen is 2
comma 6 that's right but now this
indicates that oxygen does not have 8
electrons in the outermost shell so how
will it achieve its stable state what
can be done to have 8 electrons in the
outermost orbital yes oxygen can borrow
or share electrons with atoms of other
elements right absolutely
this is how chemical reactions happen
wait a second
are we saying that chemical reactions
occur because atoms of various elements
give or take or share electrons between
them that's correct
and is this how compounds are formed
absolutely the giving or accepting or
even sharing of electrons between the
atoms of elements give rise to formation
of chemical bonds this ultimately gives
us a compound now you tell me how will
the atoms decide how many electrons are
to be given or accepted
how will they understand that electrons
need to be shared with the other partner
who decides all this well the answer to
all these questions is the concept of
valency let's understand this important
concept in detail in the upcoming video
[Music]
you